au milieu du magasin une personne qui
s'est présenté comme étant le directeur
du magasin nous a dit tout simplement
que les chiens n'étaient pas acceptées
dans son établissement il ya de
l'hygiène n'a fait que passer
moi je suis assez habitués à ce genre de
situation
[Musique]
non
je lui ai dit que c'était pas un simple
chien et que c'était un chien guide et
que de ce fait il devait rester à mes
côtés et c'était quelque chose
d'obligatoire parce que c'est prévu par
la loi
ce monsieur n'a pas voulu écouter ce que
je lui disais il était complètement sûr
de ce qu'il affirmait il nous a demandé
de quitter le quitter le magasin moi
personnellement j'étais aussi sûr de ce
que je de ce que je disais parce que la
situation était déjà arrivé je suis
resté ferme sur ma position
la situation de refus est flagrante mais
il ya quelque chose de plus grave que ça
c'est la situation de violence qui s'en
est suivi et ça c'est juste la première
fois que ça m'arrivait ça c'est pas
acceptable mais vous reversez le
fauteuil handicapé c'est un ami qui
avait déjà assisté à ce genre de
situation auparavant et qui le sert et
devant cette énième situation qui en
plus était en train de dégénérer vers
quelque chose d'assez choquant bain
juste eu la présence d'esprit de sortir
son téléphone pour constater
l'infraction et pouvoir s'en servir
comme une preuve juridique
après la vidéo donc une fois que mon ami
a coupé on était en dehors du magasin
tout cas en dehors des portiques
physiquement encore d'une dans le
magasin mais à l'extérieur de l'espace
de vente et la police a rappelé en ayant
vérifié la loi avant et a annoncé au
gérant du magasin
tu restes toi tu restes annoncé au
gérant du magasin qu'il était en tort et
qui se devait de me laisser rentrer donc
à partir de ce moment là le dirigeant
a changé tout à fait son fusil d'épaulé
et
il m'a fait des excuses et m'a dit qu'il
était complètement désolé et honteux de
la situation effectivement il peut être
juste honteux de ce qui s'est passé
monoprix a fait des excuses publiques
sur les réseaux sociaux
et moi aujourd'hui j'aimerais rentrer en
contact avec monoprix pour discuter avec
eux de la situation
comprendre ce qui s'est passé pourquoi
ça s'est si mal passé
et puis essayer de quelque chose de
dégueulasse d'en faire quelque chose de
bien
moi je les subis je veux que personne
d'autre le subissent et c'est bon combat
aujourd'hui la cause du chien guide
il faut qu'on la fasse progresser en
france parce que tout le monde
malheureusement ne connais pas cette
cette situation cette loi est trop
souvent on est refuser dans les magasins
le handicap nous limitent déjà
suffisamment dans notre autonomie il
faut pas que les hommes si m
[Musique]